Nina: Hi, Sal. Tell us a little bit about
your book and the journey
that you underwent before you
started the Khan Academy which led you
to writing this book.
Sal: Yes, well the book
is it's a little bit about
that journey, but really
the journey informed what
Khan Academy has now
become and then how that
could inform maybe what
classrooms could become
or what learning could become.
Not in just a pie in
the sky kind of way, but
this is really happening
and it really feels like
we're at this inflection point
and what's going on in classrooms.
This whole adventure
for me started somewhat,
actually very inadvertently, it was 2004.
I was working as an analyst
at a hedge fund at the time.
Just gotten married,
family from New Orleans
visiting me in Boston after
my wedding and it turned
out this one cousin,
Nadia, was having trouble.
12-years-old.
I had trouble believing that.
She's an extremely bright girl.
We share a certain amount
of DNA too. (laughter)
When I asked her about
it; it was actually her
mom who told me and I
asked Nadia about it.
She said, "Oh yeah, I'm
having trouble with units."
I said, "Let me tutor you,"
and I think she thought
I was just bluffing so I said,
"No, we're going to work this out."
She went back to New
Orleans, got on the phone.
We ended up using some
tools on the internet so we
could see each other's
scrawls initially with a mouse
and then we got these
little pen tablet things.
Long story short, she went
from being a struggling
student to catching up
with her class and then
becoming a somewhat advanced student.
I joke I became a tiger
cousin at that point. (laughs)
I called her school and I said,
"I really think Nadia needs
to retake a placement exam,"
and they said, "Who are you?"
I said, "I'm her cousin."
Then I started tutoring her
brothers and fast forward
two years, word got around
free tutoring was happening.
I was tutoring 10-15
family, friends, cousins.
It was at that point and
the firm I was working for,
it was a firm but it was
my boss and his dog and me,
we moved to Silicon Valley.
I was telling a friend
about all the stuff I was
doing with my cousins and
I was complaining that
it was getting hard to scale.
I still had a day job.
All these students around
the country with time zones,
et cetera, et cetera, and
he said, "Well, why don't
you make some tutorials,
stick them up on YouTube?"
I thought that was a silly idea.
YouTube is for cats
playing piano, not serious.
But I gave it a shot and long story short,
that started getting a ton of traction.
People started looking at it.
The reality is I was also
working on this little
software tool for my cousins
and so there was this
view that hey maybe this could be
an institution to help people.
It was set up as a
not-for-profit and then in 2009,
I had trouble focusing on my day job.
I quit and started doing
Khan Academy full time.
Nina: Tell a little bit
about the Khan Academy.
What is the business model?
Let's start with the big,
hairy, audacious school
which I just found very
big and audacious and then
the business model that
you've based it on.
Sal: Yes. Maybe I'll go
the other way around.
When I was starting all
of this and I was sitting
in the middle of Silicon Valley.
I came from a very for-profit reality.
I had friends who were
venture capitalists saying
hey Sal, we could fund
this and it could be this
double bottom line business
or whatever that means.
There was a lot of
temptation there and there's
nothing wrong with that,
but there was this feeling;
I was getting all of this
emotional reward from these
thank you letters that
people were sending me and
the sense that hey, I was
making these simple things
for my cousin and at
first tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands and
now millions of students
are using it around the world.
I'd like this stuff to be
around in a hundred years
or in 500 years and I don't
want this collection of
software and content and
this organization, I don't
want it to skew from this
mission of being able
to reach these people.
When I look at other
organizations in the universe
that are able to do that,
last many, many hopefully
centuries and stay true to a
mission, it's a not-for-profit.
Where there is no ownership;
it's a public charity.
I said, "Oh, I should set
this up as a not-for-profit,"
not quite understanding
what that is and I remember
when I was doing that
initial paperwork for it,
the IRS asks you what's your mission.
I kind of thought about
it for maybe three or four
minutes and I said a free
world class education
for anyone, anywhere.
Nina: Why not?
Sal: Why not?
Well, you know you never
want something that you could
just say check it's
done; it's an aspiration.
and it was a very delusional
aspiration at the time.
I was literally operating out of a closet.
The business model is
we're not a business.
We're a 501C3 not-for-profit,
but we still have to
sustain ourselves and the
way we want to because we
always want the learning
side of education,
we always want that to
be free because we think
that's what empowers people.
It's primarily foundation and
philanthropist driven so far,
but we do think there are
ways to sustain itself
in other ways, whether
it's licensing content
or who knows what.
We're starting to explore that,
but we're pretty true to
keeping the content free.
Nina: Sure. How many
students are you serving
right now, how many instructors?
Can you give me a sense as to how large
of an enterprise and
what's the typical profile
of someone who comes to your website?
Sal: Yes. The organization
itself, we're 36 people
so we're still relatively small.
It feels huge for me
because last year we were 13
and the year before that we were one.
We've been growing fast,
but in this past month
we reached 7 million
students, unique students.
We've reached a total
of 60 million unique.
That's the way you measure,
unique students on the web.
Delivered 180 million
lessons, 700 million problems
have been done on the site.
It's students all over the world.
Pretty much every country
in the world, someone
has used Khan Academy in some way.
Twenty thousand teachers,
as far as we can tell
from our data, are using
it in their classes or
with their cohorts in some type of way.
It's kind of crazy.
It's surreal for where it came from.
Nina: Yes, let's talk a
little bit about how a
classroom or a school
can use you, this concept
of flipped classroom.
Explain that to our viewers.
Sal: Yes and I'll do two
things because this flipped
classroom has somewhat
been tied to Khan Academy
and it is an interesting
idea and it is, I think,
a forward step, but part
of the whole point of this
whole book was to show
people we're not necessarily
about the flip; we're
about pushing the envelope
even further than the flip.
In a flip model, right now
at home, you do problems,
traditionally, that's called homework.
In the classroom, a lot of time in a
traditional classroom is spent lectures.
The flip, and it predates
Khan Academy, early on I
had these videos out there.
Some teachers were telling
me hey, you made a decent
video on meiosis or on projectile motion.
I don't have to give that lecture anymore.
My students can watch it
at their own time and pace.
They can remediate without
taking up class time.
Then when they go to
class, that's when they can
either ask me questions,
clarifications and
we can do problems together.
It used to be homework,
the problem sets could now
be done inside the classroom
and the advantage there is
the real learning occurs
when you do the engagement,
when you're doing the problem sets.
I think traditionally
students either don't do
homework or have trouble
doing homework because
there's no one at home to help them out.
Now they're in the classroom,
they have the teacher,
they have their peers
which is a under-untilized
resource in the classroom
not only to help you,
but when you help others
you learn a lot better.
It also gives the teacher a lens on
how the class is doing.
When you're lecturing,
it's very hard to know
where people are.
You might be able to poll
them, ask a few questions,
but it's very hard.
A lot of times the students
are a little bit blank faces,
but now if you're doing
problem solving together,
you can understand where students are
and diagnosis them and so that's the flip.
What used to be homework in the classroom,
what used to be lectures are now at home.
It makes the classroom interactive.
Students can get lectures
at their time and pace.
Great.
What I focus on a lot
in the book is let's go
even further because still
even the flip assumes
that all the students are
going to cover the same
material at the same pace
together and what I talk
a lot about is we've all
been indoctrinated in
the system and when I talk
about the system, I'm not
talking about what should
be the student/teacher
ratio or charter or private or public.
I'm talking about the system.
I'm talking about grouping
kids by age based cohorts.
They cover certain subjects at a set pace.
We grade them based on
their variable understanding
and then we keep pushing them forward.
We just assume that's what
school is, but what I go
to great lengths to show
is no; this is actually
a relatively new phenomenon.
It's about 200 years, I
mean it's not that new,
it's about 200 years old,
but we inherited it from
a country that no longer
exists, the Prussians.
In fairness to the Prussians
and even to us I guess,
during the Industrial
Revolution was the first time
that people seriously thought about
how can we educate everybody.
Before that, it was you're
the son of a lord, a king
and you would get a private tutor.
A private tutor was the gold standard.
They're working at your
pace, they're differentiating
it for you, but now all
of a sudden in Prussia,
there's like okay we want
to have mass education.
How do we do it in a practical way?
Whoa, it's the Industrial
Revolution; how do we do
anything in a practical way?
We stick them on an assembly line and as
they go through, we do
something to the product
and hopefully at the end
we have a decent product.
They essentially applied the
same model to classrooms.
The kids are in these
buckets based on age.
It's funny, I was talking
to a friend and her child
already knows how to
read and everything and
she was trying to get the
child into kindergarten.
He was born in October or something.
The school said oh yes,
he's a very bright kid,
but we can't; he's too small.
She came back and she's
like yes, he's too small.
I was like look, if that's
what they were concerned
about, they should be
grouping them by size.
That's the obvious
natural...but that's the model.
Even the flip is in the
context of that model.
On week three we cover parabolas.
Week four we cover systems of equations.
We give students grades.
We give them a B and that
B shows that they have
a gap in their knowledge, a
C, even a D you can get on
an exam, but then you
move on to the next topic.
That's usually building
on top of that which is
pretty much dooming you to failure.
Nina: Exactly.
Sal: What I advocate
strongly and we're already
seeing this in schools
starting to experiment or
move in this direction
is if you take lecture
out of the classroom,
there's no longer the need for everyone
to move together at the
same pace and as soon as
you get rid of that
assumption, you can completely
rethink what a classroom can be.
You can start having everyone
learn at their own pace.
You can leverage class
time for when humans are
together for actual interactivity.
You can start to say
well why do we only have
one teacher in the room;
why can't have two teachers in the room?
Why do we have a bell ringing?
This bell ringing, this
is like a factory in
a 19th Century factory.
Why do we have a bell
ringing that's saying stop
what you were doing on chemistry,
you must now start English?
Anyone who's ever done
anything creative knows that's
the best way to stop creativity is to say
you have exactly 55 minutes
and then you're done.
What we're advocating is
move to a reality possibly
with the help of tools
like Khan Academy so that
every student can learn at their own pace,
teachers have dashboards,
tools that empower them
and use class time for
interactivity and creativity.
Nina: Right, right.
You touched on this a little
bit, but explain a little
bit about why is it that
your platform has taken off
and is getting so much
attention when so many others
who were kind of doing
the same thing on the
for-profit side, some
on the non-profit side,
haven't succeeded?
Sal: It's an open question.
It's a question that we
are constantly asking
ourselves is because whatever
the "secret sauce" is
we don't want to lose it
somewhere in the process.
My best guess of why; there
was this initial wave of
traction from 2006 to it
continues to grow, is those
first videos, I think
it was fortunate it was
just some guy making it for his cousins.
Nina: They were easy to use.
Sal: They were easy to use.
They felt very human.
I think the big learning
is that people were
hungry; you know I wasn't
the first person to make
videos on YouTube.
I wasn't the first person
to think of teaching.
As soon as radio came out,
people were saying, oh we'll use this to
teach the world and then
TV, oh we'll use this to
VCR and now it's on demand.
Historically, it was either
a videotape of someone
at a chalk board, traditional
class which feels distant
even when you're in the classroom.
You're there, I'm over
here, the next step in the
equation and you do it like that.
That's not varied and when
you make that in a video
it's even harder to see.
What are they writing
there and I can't hear them
and these felt very personal.
You're sitting next to me.
The other dimension of it is
just a conversational tone.
I think a lot of people,
they try to make it very
polished which is not
bad, but in that process
you lose the humanity.
It sounds like your GPS system.
The next step in this
equation is when. (laughs)
I think, hopefully, this
is something that I try to
put into it is one of the
things that I think allowed
me to thrive in math and
science and eventually
even finance was I felt
like I had a really holistic
understanding of things
and my basics were really,
really, really solid.
My basics in algebra were
really good so when I went
into calculus I was like oh
this is intuitive and when
I went into corporate finance,
I was like oh this is intuitive.
There's nothing new here.
You see other really,
really smart people, they're
just learning for the next
exam, memorizing formulas,
then they forget it and
then when they see a related
concept, it's like what's this.
What I tried in those early
days for my cousins is
give a sense of intuition,
draw the connections
between things so that when
they see this new concept,
it's not some random new concept.
It's connected to everything
they learned before.
I get a lot of letters.
I would have assumed that
would only be appealing
to the motivated kids, so
to speak, but I get a lot
of letters from kids who
were traditionally disengaged
or demotivated and they
said that's why I was
demotivated; no one
was explaining the why.
No one was giving me the connections.
Hopefully that's why people have been
connecting to the content.
Nina: Yes. Let's talk a
little bit about virtual
education and offering the types of things
that you're offering.
A lot of people are still a
little wary of these reforms.
They see it as a mechanism
to ultimately get rid of
teachers in the classroom
or reduce class sizes.
You talk a little bit
about this in the book.
Explain that a little bit more.
Sal: Yes, yes and I think
that's a super important
point because when we've
learned in the last
15-20 years with the
internet, whenever people see
virtual X, it's like is
that going to replace the
physical; Barnes and
Noble versus Amazon.com.
There's a natural contention there.
That's the exact opposite
of what I think is going
to happen in education.
Everything we do is not
going to replace a physical school.
I have young kids.
I want them to go to a physical school.
I want them to get interaction.
What it will do is, I think,
will give all of our children
the experience that I
think every parent and
every teacher or every
student wants to be a part of.
Even now we're going through
a physical experience,
but we're not leveraging the humans.
We're going, but for the
most part people are sitting
passively there and they're listening.
It's hard for the teachers
too because it's hard to
speak for 60 minutes without
getting that connection
with the students.
What we're advocating is
leverage tools so that you
can get maybe information
delivery out of the way
so that you can get some
of the problem solving
out of the way.
When people go and they
have class time, the scarce
class time with other
human beings, then that's
optimally interactive
and not interactive in
the web sense, interactive
in the human sense.
Class time is all conversation.
Class time is all peer tutoring
and working with their teacher.
Class time is all doing
open-ended projects.
I talk about this in the
book and I give a TED talk.
The irony here is I strongly
believe, and it's not just
talk again, we're seeing
this in classrooms,
is that you can actually
use technology to make
the classroom more human.
I'm very careful; you
mentioned there is skepticism.
I think there should be.
I'm skeptical when
someone says hey, we just
ordered 500 iPads for our
school and I say what are
you going to do with it
or how are you going to
integrate it into the
curriculum or how are you
going to leverage it to
fundamentally transform
what's going on and there usually
aren't a lot of answers there.
I think it is good to be
skeptical, but at the same time
there is, I think, a reason for hope.
Nina: How do you evaluate
the impact of your courses,
since again you talk about
grades in your book and
how you don't like the concept of grading.
How do you know that they
have actually worked?
Sal: Yes and I'll tell you
when I grew up, I remember
I sometimes would meet
people who said I don't
believe in grades and I
thought they were these
granola bar, hippy type
people and now I think
I appreciate what they were saying.
Grades, normally when you
say to people who don't
like grades, you really
think that they're being
touchy-feely, they're not
being rigorous, but actually
they're saying grades
aren't rigorous enough.
Grades are this thing that
give this feeling of rigor,
oh A, B, As, you really know your stuff,
F, you don't know your stuff.
One, they're somewhat arbitrary.
It depends on the test,
depends on how it's measured.
Even more than that, when
you give grades especially
in the sense if you had
a C on an exam, you have
obvious weaknesses,
assuming that it was even a
good exam, you have obvious weaknesses.
That should be used as an
assessment to say okay,
you need to now improve
on those weaknesses.
Before we move on to
a more advanced topic,
it's common sense, get your basics down.
Instead we use grades
as a value judgement.
You're smart. You're dumb.
You're fast. You're slow.
That's just going to be a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
What we say is let's make sure
everyone masters every concept.
Rather than having a
superficial understanding
of algebra and then moving
over onto trigonometry,
make sure you really
understand algebra deeply
and then trigonometry is going to make
a lot more sense.
It's going to be a lot
easier to learn and if you
master trigonometry,
calculus is going to start
seeming very intuitive.
In terms of how we're doing
it, we're working with
schools, most famously
Los Altos which is now
using Khan Academy, it's
probably one of the best,
if not the best, school
district in the country,
is using Khan Academy
for 5th through 8th grade
as one of the tools that
they use and there we have
formal studies going on
to understand exactly
how this impacting
students and teachers both
objectively on things like
test scores and grades,
but also subjectively.
Are the teachers more
excited about their work?
Are the students excited about their work?
Then on top of that, we
have 3 million problems done
a day on our site.
We have this huge number
of students, 7 million
a month using our site.
We have this treasure trove of data
on our side ourselves and
we are building an analytics tool.
Nina: Monitoring it daily.
Sal: Yes. All the stuff
that all these other
web companies are able
to do, we as a kind of
education not-for-profit
can now do using analytics,
optimizing for engagement,
see what kind of
learning is going on.
Nina: Great, great. Tell
me a little bit about;
you gave a great historical
overview of how we came
to educate students today,
the way we're educating them.
Did you always hold
these views and know this
information before you
stumbled on the Khan Academy
or this platform you
created or were these things
that you studied afterwards?
It just so happens that everything
flows so beautifully. (laughs)
Sal: It's been very serendipitous.
Nina: I was curious as to what came first.
Sal: It's been a combination.
I actually think it's more of the latter.
Obviously all of us have
spent a lot of time in
the system.
I think the whole time,
anybody who knew me
growing up, they knew that
I was always why is this
this way, why is it that why.
Why can't I tutor?
I used to get reprimanded
for trying to tutor.
I said no, this would have been
a really positive interaction.
This question, did you go to college
and you're like all these
people sitting in this
lecture hall, is anything
really happening in here?
It seems like all the
learning is happening
in the cram session three
days before the final.
There were always these
ideas and then obviously
when I started working with my cousins.
I started seeing my cousins
were motivated, they were
for the most part good
students, but they were having
these huge gaps in their knowledge.
They weren't learning things intuitive.
Nina: It's called Swiss cheese learning.
Sal: Swiss cheese learning.
I, in very pragmatic ways,
started building these
tools and it was really
a process of discovery
of teachers emailing me
saying hey, we're using it
this way or we're using it that way.
It's a combination of these
instincts of how did I learn,
how do other people that
I know who learn things
holistically, how did they
learn, what am I seeing
with my cousins, what
are teachers telling me.
As Khan Academy got more
traction, I started having
people tell me about a lot of this stuff.
I knew a little bit
about the history before.
I'd heard about this whole
Committee of Ten on 1890.
Someone told me about that
in high school, but it was
interesting that even the
research, the reason why I
made the videos so short
was because YouTube limited
me to ten minutes but then
I used to have researchers
telling that no, there's
actually cognitive research
that shows that's where a
lot of research from the book
comes from, actually
people, especially dense
academic content, can't
pay attention for more than
ten or fifteen minutes.
It starts as wow, why are
we do these, why are we
using class time, this time
with human beings for these
hour long lectures,
sometimes 90 minute lectures.
Can't we get people to interact more?
The more I did research,
a lot of these basic
common sense ideas gelled
with research and that's
when you feel best about it.
It's weird when research
tells you something very
non-intuitive, but here
it's telling you something
very, very, very intuitive
and the only hard to graph
thing is that we're very indoctrinated
into a strange model.
Nina: Yes, yes. It all makes sense.
Tell me a little bit
about your own education.
Something despite the
regimented system that you grew
up in, something must have gone right.
Was it a teacher? Was it
your parents you think who
built this sense of inquisitiveness?
Did you go to a particular
type of school that
was open to nurturing
you as an individual and
paying attention to your specific needs?
Did none of these things work?
Sal: Yes, yes. I would
be delusional, although
I am sometimes delusional,
if I were to say none on
of that stuff played in.
I think there was probably
two, I mean there's probably
a bunch of different
factors and I'm probably
forgetting some of them.
One, I was blessed to have
an older sister who was
a very good student so
I think that projected.
When I would walk into a
classroom, teachers would
remember my sister and say
oh, you're Farrah's brother.
You must be and I was
like in speech therapy
and stuff, but they would project that.
There's actually studies
now that show that that
projection has huge
implications for your own
self-esteem so that was luck.
On top of that, I went
to just, I would say, it
was a public school in Jefferson Parish.
Public schools in Jefferson
Parish, right outside
of New Orleans, I would
say it was the average
American public schools, all of them.
Elementary, middle and high school.
There were some incredible teachers there.
I think in high school in
particular Mr. Hernandez,
Miss Kennedy.
Miss Kennedy was the
journalism teacher and actually
I would say that's where
a lot of the ideas,
class should not be a lecture.
Class should be working
alongside the teacher.
It was journalism class
so we had a product,
a creative product, a
newspaper to work on.
I was the art editor and
she would give us feedback
and she was like our senior peer, and I
remember those interactions
and a lot of the experience
I got from journalism,
I still think about when
I'm working on Khan Academy.
I think early in my schooling,
I think this was key
and also lucky, I got into
- I don't what they call
it now - these GT programs
and what they did is
you have this very structured
Prussian curriculum
for most of the day, but
then one day a week they
take you out of a different
classroom and they
take you into these GT classrooms.
There, you'd go into
this classroom which is
essentially the kind of
classroom ideally everyone
should have where you
have this, it was actually
Miss Rucell and Miss Krause.
These two teachers and
they had PhDs in education.
I remember the first day
walking into GT and Miss Rucell
said what do you want to do.
I was like 8 and I was like
I like to draw and then
she says well you should
draw more then, but she
would introduce me to these
things, different styles,
different tools to draw.
What else are you interested in?
I was like I like puzzles
and she's like well here
are some puzzles and she would give me
these brain teasers.
She was mentoring me and
it was self-paced and I
was able to go at my own
pace and there were other
kids working on interesting
things and I would get
inspired by them, sometimes
we would work on things.
I think we needed that breathing room.
I wonder if I didn't have
that experience early on
in my life whether I would
have had the ability to
self-direct or have the ability to say
let me solve that problem.
That's an interesting thing to tackle.
Nina: Right.
Along those lines, do
you have any advice for
parents out there, first
graders, second graders,
and I'm asking you this
because in your book, you
also highlight how a lot
of students in southeast
Asia go to school in order
to show off what they know,
not necessarily to learn in school.
Are there habits that you
think parents can start
to put in place early on,
despite how schools are
approaching education?
Sal: Yes and take everything
I say with a grain of salt.
I have a 3-year-old and
a 1-year-old so maybe I
should be getting advice
from the parents of 7- or
8-year-olds.
I'm trying to get my
1-year-old off of a pacifier.
Nina: You know iPads are very popular.
Sal: No, you're absolutely right.
My sense, having gone
through the system and even
observing, we're working
with a lot of teachers,
we're working with a lot of schools now,
I would say there's a
couple dimensions here.
I think it is true.
Asians, whether it's
East Asians, South Asian,
there is a culture of school
is where you go to show
what you've already learned
at home and I think that
gives those students an
advantage of having this
kind of buffer of they're
learning stuff maybe ahead.
I'm not saying that
necessarily has to be the way,
but that is a way to ensure
that your student in the
Prussian model doesn't
fall behind and as soon as
they fall behind, all of
these negative self-perception
things and they start
to reinforce each other.
I'll tell you what I would
do with my own children.
I would do some combination
of engaging them with
a lot of the content before
it becomes stressful.
When I was teaching Nadia
algebra when she was in
algebra class, it was
stressful for her because
she was like I need to catch
up, I have an exam on it.
When I started teaching
algebra to her younger brother,
who's in 5th grade, he
thought it was fun because
there's no stress here.
It was just this fun thing
his cousin was teaching.
At least expose your kids
to the ideas of algebra
and physics and biology
and chemistry early on so
when they see it in school,
they've already had some exposure.
The other thing I would say
is don't over schedule them.
I think sometimes the same
parents that would do the
teaching ahead of time, at
the same time would also
you have piano lessons,
you have soccer lessons,
you have everything.
I think there's value there
definitely but if it's
complete over-scheduling,
you have the loss of the
time for the child to
develop their own creativity.
Kind of what I had in that GT class.
Frankly in the '80s, I was
a latch-key child where
mom, she worked these
odd jobs and come home at
6:00 or 7:00 so my sister
and I, we would just hangout.
Some of it was wasted watching
TV, but a lot of it was
I want to build something
or I want to draw or
we would make up games
and stuff like that.
Kids need that, they need
that free space and maybe
if they are blowing it
all on video games or
watching TV, you need to
push them a little bit
or do something creative with them.
They need that time for creativity.
The last thing I would
recommend is that the parents
themselves engage in learning because
you set that example.
If you are 40 or 50-years-old
and you're going back
and learning algebra and
cosmology or English Lit.,
it's a huge signal for students.
Nina: Right, right.
Let's talk about your vision
for the ideal classroom
or this futuristic vision
that you outline here
about what the school of
tomorrow should look like
which is a life long learning
approach to education.
You also talk about the college
of tomorrow to look like.
I was fascinated by this,
but let's talk just about
schooling, your notions
of class size, the ideal
classroom could potentially
have 100 students in it
with four instructors roaming around
and helping students.
We talked a little bit
about grades already,
but testing.
This is one of those topics
that comes up a lot here
in Washington and with the
discussions on Capitol Hill.
How would you describe
that vision for us and you
also talk about how you
would get rid of summer
vacations which is probably
not going to be popular?
Yes, let's dive into this a bit.
Sal: Yes, no there's a lot there.
The first dimension is once
you remove lecture from
class time, you say class
time is time for interaction,
you can have students
working at their own pace,
allows you to rethink everything.
A lot of the concepts in this book
and a lot of these are happening.
There are schools that
we're working with that are
doing these things.
They are experiments, but
they're experiments that
all the research and all
the intuition point in
that direction.
Teaching is, for the most
part, a solitary profession.
You're the only teacher in the room.
Nina: It's a lonely profession, yes.
Sal: It's lonely.
You can have 100 students,
you're not changing the
students/teacher ratio,
you might even improve it,
but you now have four
teachers in the same room.
Now if one of them gets
sick, students don't ahve
a substitute teacher.
Different students are
going to connect with
different teachers.
They can mentor each other;
they can do group things
with teachers together.
There's a whole dimension
that you could add.
You could have a physics
teacher, a math teacher,
a chemistry teacher and
a biology teacher all
teaching simultaneously
so students understand all
these sciences and math blend together.
They're not these siloed
subjects so they get
a holistic understanding.
The tests themselves, you
need some aspect of testing,
but you should be very
skeptical of testing because
all tests measure what
they test and there's many
more facets to a human being than that.
The dimensions, there could
be some testing to make
sure that students are
getting core competency
and some core skills, but
the more important skills,
which I think are completely
unmeasured right now,
are creativity and you
can never give someone a
creativity score but you can have someone
generate a portfolio of creative works.
We, as an employer, we're
hiring engineers and we
get these people with
great GPAs from top schools
in the country and say
what have you created.
That's what engineering
is, building new things,
and they haven't created
anything because they've
been on the treadmill the whole time,
just trying to finish problem sets
and they're very, very, smart people.
The ideal is that students
over their careers can
show what they've created.
It's not like they write
a paper, it gets graded,
and it gets thrown away.
They write a paper, it
gets graded and they keep
working on the paper;
they keep developing it.
When they're 18, they have a novel done.
They have a bunch of
papers on policy done.
They can show people this is my work.
They have computer programs written; they
build robots and on top of
that, and this is another
dimension that's completely
missed in the Prussian
model so to speak, is I think
in any field, the people
you want to work with the
most are the people who
have deep subject matter
expertise but are also always
willing to help others and
they have that communication
and that ability to empathize.
In our current system, we
make everyone very focused
on themselves.
What are your grades?
Are you going to pass a test?
Cram for the next exam.
In the model that we're
describing, that we're
starting to see in a lot of schools, let's
focus everyone on each other.
Yes, you go at your own
pace, you might be racing
ahead and that's great.
You're stimulated, you're
engaged, but you also
have a chance to re-engage
with students who might
be having difficulty
and there's two things.
One, you're going to
be helping that student
but even better when you
explain that, hopefully,
and you develop your ability to explain,
you learn the material better,
and you'll learn to communicate,
you'll learn to empathize and that
actually is measurable.
You can have students rate each other.
You can have people write
assessments for each other.
Oh, he understood this
stuff, but he spoke a little
fast and you can develop that aspect.
I'd imagine that transcript
of the future, and I say the
future, that future is
now, is yes you would
have your test scores.
Your test scores are actual competency;
it wouldn't be grades.
It would be like yes, I understand algebra
and I've renewed it.
I've renewed that I know algebra well.
I know cosmology and I'm a writer
and here's my writings.
You have a portfolio of
your creative works in
multi-dimensions and you
have reviews from people
that you've helped saying
great person to work with,
really understood the subject matter,
really able to communicate
well and those are
the things that I think
anyone would actually
care about more than just test scores.
Nina: Right, but let's
talk a little bit about
what happens in this
classroom or school in terms
in terms of subjects.
You believe that right
now you have to take math,
you have to take English
language arts, you start
science at a certain point in time.
Do you believe that all
these basics should also
be thought in this
school and at what point,
another question that
I wanted to ask is do
you believe that all
children can learn unless
they have a serious disability?
Can they all progress to
the levels that you have
progressed to if they
simply learn and master
and show an interest really
in the subject matter
that they're studying?
Specifically vis'a'vie,
the STEM fields which are
science, technology, engineering, and math
which are areas kids tend
not to get interested in.
Is it just because they
haven't mastered it well
and been pushed to
understand it early on or
are there limitations
perhaps in how we are
currently trying to get students
to learn these subjects?
Sal: Yes, so on the latter
question if you would
have asked me 20 years
ago, I would have said yeah
maybe certain people
are predisposed to math
and science and other
people aren't and that made
me feel good because I
was one of those people
who were predisposed.
It made me feel like I
was meant to be there;
it wasn't luck, but my
experience with my cousins,
Nadia in particular but
other cousins, and then
what we're seeing schools.
The schools that are
transitioning to this type
of a model where all the
students are learning
at their own pace,
building their foundations,
we're seeing day five, yes.
Some kids have raced ahead.
Well those are the gifted
kids and some kids are
falling behind; well maybe
they need to be remediated.
Traditional model, you
would separate them and you
would tell these kids
you're smart and you would
tell these kids, either
explicitly or implicitly,
you're not as smart.
What we're seeing is if
you keep them together,
but you allow them to work
at their own pace so that
they're engaged, they have
mentorship from each other
and the teacher, many times it's actually
quite hard to predict,
we're trying to predict but
it's very hard, some of these students
were falling behind.
Maybe it's an algebra class
and some of them didn't
know multiplication well.
Some of them didn't know
how to add fractions.
You give them an
opportunity to really build
that foundation on negative
numbers,multiplication,
exponents, whatever it might be,
and these kids race ahead.
They're problem wasn't that they had some
cognitive inability to understand algebra.
The problem was they're
sitting in an algebra class
and for some reason they
didn't understand how to
multiply or they didn't know
how to add fractions and
then you're just going to feel
silly in an algebra class.
You'll disengage really just to protect
your own self-esteem.
I'm actually now more
and more convinced that
pretty much everyone,
barring certain exceptions,
could - we don't know
where; we're still learning;
we don't know - progress far ahead
and we're seeing it in these classrooms.
We traditionally think
motivated kids, maybe
that's 20% of kids, but as
soon as you allow people
to engage and fill in gaps
without feeling embarrassed,
you start seeing it's
not 20%; it's 80 or 90%
of kids can start to feel engaged.
In terms of the first
question about what subjects,
I think it is interesting
and I talk a little bit
about it is the subjects that are
taught now are somewhat arbitrary.
They were decided in 1892
by the Committee of Ten,
male university presidents
who didn't know about;
this was before the
Federal Reserve existed,
the interstate highways
existed, knowledge of DNA
and a whole bunch of other stuff, and they
decided that at age 14
you should learn algebra,
at age 15 you should
learn geometry, at age 16
you should learn trigonometry.
You should learn physics your
senior year in high school.
That's when it was decided
and it hasn't changed since.
I love all those subjects,
I think they're all
fascinating, but I think
there are obvious questions.
Should there be more statistics?
Is statistics more valuable than calculus
or at least as valuable?
Should there be some
knowledge of economics?
Who knows what it would be.
It's for society to decide,
but the general idea
is at minimum should be
rethought in the last 120 years.
There are grounds, the world has changed.
We should think more about
what these subjects are.
Even more I think and you eluded to this,
should they even be divvied
up in this siloed subjects?
These siloed subjects,
we're indoctrinated into it
so it's hard for us to
break our minds from it.
This is the factory model.
This is you're at this
machine in the factory so this
is what will be poured into the product.
Okay, now you're going to
have the paint applied to you.
You're going to have the
chemistry applied to you.
Now you move on and for
some people that might
chip a little bit; that's fine.
They'll be a cheaper
product at the end, but the
reality is chemistry is
halfway in between physics
and biology and physics
is halfway in between
chemistry and pure
mathematics and all of them
actually have an aspect
of philosophy to them.
All of them have an aspect
of aesthetics to them
and whatever else and
writing can be critical and
logical thinking is across all programs.
You could have something
like logic which is
across everything.
I think the reality
we're moving to is yes,
you will show competency in things.
Yes, I understand this
domain well so you can go
take an exam and then
renew that exam to show
that yes, I still understand
that topic but while
you're in school, some might
be preparation for that
particular competency,
but most of the time
we'll be blending it
where you're not working
to pass an assessment;
you're working to create things.
In the process of creating
things, whether it might
be a novel or a robot or a business,
you're integrating all of these things.
Anyone who's started a
business, if you're in a
tech business, there's
art and design, there's
technology, there's quantitative
thinking and there's
writing and there's just
human skills and you
need to integrate them.
That's what actually
matters in the real world.
When you break yourself
from this assembly line
model, you give yourself the freedom
for people to pursue these type of things.
Nina: Why not create a Khan
Academy charter school?
Why not a Khan Academy private school?
Sal: Yes.
Nina: I'm sure you've
thought of it at least once.
Sal: We go back and forth on that, but
we're thinking about it.
We're thinking about it.
Nina: Where would you
put it, which country
would you pick?
Sal: Well for selfish
reasons, I would probably
put it in Mountainview,
California which is within
walking distance, but
seriously I think it's
interesting and this
shows the emphasis we put;
I think a physical experience is
incredibly, incredibly important.
A lot of people in Silicon
Valley say well you're
at scale already, you're
reaching 7 million and you're
growing, you're doubling
every year, you could
reach 100 million students
in five years, maybe a
billion and why are you
even thinking about physical
or why are you thinking
about physical schools.
I would say well that's
because that's the core and I
also think you need...You
might say well why focus
on one school that
might be able to reach a
few hundred kids when you're able to reach
100 million maybe one day?
The idea is if you can
show examples of this,
and there are schools
that have already moved in
that direction. Los Altos
has moved in that direction.
Summit Prep, which is a charter school,
they've broken down walls.
They have multiple teachers
teaching classes in
these epic environments.
If you show examples of
this, then I think that's
what moves the dial forward.
Nina: How much would be the tuition?
Sal: The tuition would be...
Nina: He's looking at Avenues, the school
in New York, $40,000 a child.
Sal: That's the interesting thing.
Nina: It was built without
this book and a vision
behind it, right. A lot of marketing.
Sal: The money is fascinating.
Education is; someone
asked me recently could you
ever spend too much on
education and to some degree
the answer is no.
It's such an important
thing, but at the same time
if you're going to spend that much money,
you have to think
seriously about how you're
spending it and I've
met with some officials
about this.
A public level, charter,
private schools and
regardless of school, I
say how much do you spend
per pupil per year.
If you ask a private school,
some of them $25,000,
$30,000, $40,000 a year.
You ask a public school,
some states as low it goes
down to $5-6,000 a year but most states,
especially on the east
coast, it's $10-15,000.
New York City public schools $18,000,
Cambridge, Massachusetts $25,000
per year per student.
I say okay, what's your
average class size and they'll
usually say number between 20 and 30.
I said okay private
school, you're charging
$30,000 a year, there's 20 students.
That's $600,000 per classroom.
It's essentially for what's
directly impacting the
students, the teachers, the classroom
and maybe the textbooks.
All I can figure out is
maybe there's $100,000,
$150,000 being spent there.
Where's the other quarter
of a million or $300,000?
Same thing at any level.
Why can't we instead use;
the private school I think
for $10,000 a year, instead
of $40,000, $10,000 a year,
let's say you have 30 students in a class.
That's $300,000 a year.
I say pay the teacher $150,000.
A lot of people pay lip service to you.
Oh, teaching should be
on par with doctors,
engineers and lawyers.
That's nice lip service but
if you really believe that,
pay teachers the same as
doctors, engineers and lawyers.
That's the best signal to
society that you actually
value it, but the money is clearly there.
It'll have to get cut from
all the stuff that's not
impacting the students.
I don't know, every time
I ask this to people,
I just do this back of
the envelope calculation.
This is what I used to
do in my old career.
I used to speak to CFOs,
say you're making this much;
what am I missing?
Same exact question;
$15,000 times 30 students is
$450,000 a year.
The fully loaded cost
of the teacher is less
than half of that.
Where's that money going?
I think you could do a
very good model for what
public schools are spending,
definitely some of the
school systems that are
spending $10,000 plus.
Nina: Talk a little bit
about how Bill Gates came
to discover you and I
just thought that chapter
was so interesting.
Yes. What was it like to
find out all of a sudden
that Bill Gates was watching your videos?
What went through your mind?
Sal: I used to wake up
in the morning sometimes,
wondering if that was all made up
or a dream or something.
The site had already gotten
traction, but summer of
2010, one of our first
donors, Ann Door, started
sending me text messages
than Bill Gates was
at the Aspen Ideas
Festival telling the whole
audience that he uses a site
that he thinks is great,
called the Khan Academy.
He uses it with his kids
and he uses it himself,
which made me a little
nervous because those videos
were for Nadia, and I
didn't know what to do.
Do I reach out to him?
I don't think he's listed.
Then two weeks later, his
chief-of-staff called and
said you might have heard
Bill's a fan and I was like
yeah, yeah I heard that.
They said if you're free,
we'd like to fly you up.
I was looking at my calendar,
it was completely blank.
I think I could make some time for Bill.
I've got to cut my nails,
but other than that
my schedule is flexible.
I went up and really
articulated, now at this time
it was mainly the videos that I was doing,
I was like look if we
could get some resources
and I was dreaming about a
five person team and some
office space, that was
the dream at that point.
We could build out the
software that I started
doing with my cousins.
Students could get practice,
they could feedback,
we could start building
a community on the site
so that students can
start helping each other.
We could build dashboards
for teachers so that
they could use it to diagnose students and
leverage class time more effectively.
Him and then later Google
as well, they were strong
believers in that.
Nina: Great. You talk a
little bit about talent
and creativity in your
book and we talked a little
bit about this earlier
on, but do you think
the advent of all these,
not the advent but a couple
years ago, there were
books focused on talent,
Talent is Overrated, The
Talent Code, you name it
and I've read all of
them myself as I have a
7-year-old who I'm trying
to foster into a talented
individual, do you think
talent and creativity
are things that can be in
fact taught to children?
Sal: I don't think they're...I'm
not sure and in fact,
I think no one is sure.
My sense, through both
observation and even seeing
what's happening there,
is it's not something that's taught,
but it's something that can be untaught.
It can be fostered or
it can be suppressed,
both talent and creativity.
I think everyone is born with creatitivy.
There's not a 2-year-old
on the planet who if you
introduce a new object
into the room will not
walk up to that object
and manipulate it in
every way, taste it, feel
it, see what they can
do with it, pour something.
There's not a 2-year-old on the planet.
There's not a 5-year-old,
actually most 5-year-olds
will still, a new object
in the room, they will
engage with it, a new idea,
they'll ask questions about it.
Then something happens
where they're taught
to become more passive.
To some degree, they're
in an environment where
questioning is not always cool.
They're so overwhelmed with work,
whether it's soccer
practice or homework, that
there's no time for them to kind of just
think about something.
The class is moving on, why
can't they think about it.
Why am I carrying the one,
that doesn't make sense;
this seems just like a formula to me.
They don't have time
for that type of stuff.
All of these things fall
from this idea of just
breaking from this Prussian
model, breaking from
this one pace fits lecture.
As soon as you take that
out, now all of a sudden
you can say hey, why
can't we let a student -
If there's a 16-year-old
some place in the country
who has just some insight
on like well maybe cancer
can be addressed and maybe
this is what cancer is,
too bad, the bell's going
to ring or they have
an AP test the next day
or they have an exam.
They're like oh well, I
have too much work to do.
I quote an admissions officer in the book,
talk about she was
interviewing a bunch of people
who were coming to a very
elite college and said
what do you daydream about
and the one student said,
"We don't daydream about
anything because it doesn't
help us to get into
college," and that's tragic.
It's tragic for that
child, but it's tragic for
society because it's those
daydreams that eventually
lead to actual; I'll tell you.
Khan Academy exists to a
large degree because my
boss at the hedge fund,
very non traditional for
that field, had a strong
belief in life work and
balance and so I had
time to daydream about
the Khan Academy.
I had time and my wife
was a resident, a medical
resident so I felt bad
sitting and vegging and
watching TV and so I was
able to think about this
problem and make resources.
I think anyone is capable of doing that.
We just have to give them the time and the
breathing room to do that.
Nina: Especially now since
it appears, I don't know
if this was in your book, I
heard it from Tom Freedman.
Most of the jobs of tomorrow
are going to be jobs
that are created, not
jobs that currently exist.
Sal: The Prussian model
started in the Industrial
Revolution and in Industrial
Revolution, we needed
probably more educated
people than we needed
in an agrarian civilization.
You needed people who
could read the directions
and have the discipline of
the assembly line and all
of that, but there was
also a certain passivity
that you also had to implicate.
In the farm, there's a
certain independence and
freedom to it.
All of a sudden in a
factory, you're doing this
over and over again.
One can debate whether
it was explicitly done,
but there was an element
of instilling that
passivity and indoctrination
so that people
could be good workers.
Before the pyramid was
like this; you needed
a few knowledge workers
who were doing creative
things and then you
needed a mass of labor.
Now the pryamid is kind
of inverted where we need
a lot of creative people,
in fact all the careers
now are creative focus and open-ended,
and you need very little physical labor.
In that reality, we're
training people for this
while we need the opposite.
Nina: Since we are in the
nation's capitol, do you
have any advice for
Congress or the President?
How can they best help
bring this vision to life,
understanding that?
Sal: That's a very interesting
question because we
do meet with state officials
and federal officials,
even in other countries,
ministries of education
and the one thing that I
don't want to happen is
right now it's been a very
grassroots, ground up thing.
People have word of mouthed Khan Academy.
People have been using it,
parents have been telling
parents, teachers have
been telling teachers and
that's good because that's
from people who want
to make it work and they
figure out and they tell
us ways to make it work better.
As soon as you make it top
down, I think it becomes
no one likes it anymore
and so we want this to
be very grassroots.
Whatever I tell people is
just tell people about it.
Tell people at minimum
they have a free tutor.
Tell teachers that look,
there might be another
model that you probably will enjoy more.
There are ways to reach
more students and on top of
that and I'm serious about this,
I think they should set an example.
It's too easy now in our
society for people to say
oh, I'm not good at math
and they'll say about
6th grade math.
That's math; I don't understand it.
No one will say oh, I can't
read at a 6th grade level
or I can barely write.
No one says that, but
you'll hear politicians
say that, you'll hear
CEOs say that, you'll hear
people in the press say
that and I think that
messaging should change.
Frankly, the only way
that could change is if
they directly engage with it.
It's shocking how many
people are engaged in
education policy when they don't know the
subject matter themselves.
Oh, I'm not good at
math, but this is how we
should test math teachers.
That's crazy.
You, yourself, should
engage in the content or
get adept in the content
and that will be a huge
signal to society and
I think it'll also help
inform policy and I think
the more they do that,
they'll realize it's a
lot less about top down,
a lot less about the controls.
The controls that they
do at every iteration of
ed reform is just about
more controls on teachers
and it might derisk some
of the weaker players,
but it also handicaps all the rest.
It gets to this culture of
everyone getting to mediocre
and what we really need
to do is go the other way,
have it be much more grassroots.
What I point out in this book,
that's an American thing.
We're a country that's
focused on creativity.
focused on people taking
ownership over their lives,
but our school system
is a Prussian one, one
that's about passivity,
one that's about authority.
Everything about this book is
let's make our school
system more American.
Nina: Any final thoughts?
If you were sitting with
President Obama at the
White House, aside from asking him to use
his Bully Pulpit more,
what would you tell him?
Sal: I'm somewhat about,
I would ask him to;
this is a somewhat
different dimension, but we
talk about this in the book.
I would ask him to make
content for us because
I think what's happening
right now is the public
discourse gets so destroyed
in these 30 second
sound bytes that you can't
have a chance to go deep
on either side of the aisle.
Right now, the main adult
learning happens on the
24-hour news and it's in
these 30 second sound bytes.
No one really understands
the issues and it just
becomes very emotionally charged.
This form factor or this
way, it's a chance for
Obama to really explain why he makes the
decisions he does and
maybe the opposition to
really explain and get
to it and diagram it out
and even have a quiz
afterwards to make sure
people are retaining it.
It would fill in that gap
in learning that frankly
people are creating.
Some of our most popular
videos are about credit
default swaps or about
the healthcare plan or
the electoral college.
These are gaps in people's
learning and adults of
any age want to learn that.
Nina: Well, it was a
pleasure reading this book.
It was nice meeting you.
Thanks for joining us.
Sal: Oh no, it was a pleasure.